Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  都退完了然后也没花手续费什么的
Shure: All refunded, and no handling fees or anything.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 卧槽
Katrina: Damn.
Katrina:  手抖
Katrina: Hand's shaking.
Shure:  喝多了手抖了开始
Shure: Drank too much, hands are shaking now.
Shure:  你他妈给他画一个
Shure: Damn, draw one for him.
Katrina: 尾巴
Katrina: A tail.
Katrina:  别瞎想
Katrina: Don't overthink it.
Shure:  我以为是
Shure: I thought it was...
Katrina:  你以为你以为
Katrina: You thought, you thought...
Shure:  尾巴都长一撮毛了
Shure: The tail even has a tuft of hair.
Katrina:  给他配一个英文的
Katrina: Give it an English name.
Katrina:  呦呼就这样
Katrina: Yeah, just like that.
Shure: 我们我们给他起个名吧
Shure: Let's give it a name.
Shure:  叫
Shure: Call it...
Katrina:  线条小狗
Katrina: Line Dog.
Katrina:  创作日期
Katrina: Creation date.
Katrina:  创作大师亲笔签名Lyx
Katrina: Signed by the master artist, Lyx.
Shure:  你好摄像头
Shure: Hello, camera.
Katrina:  这画的Hellokitty有点抽象
Katrina: This Hello Kitty is a bit abstract.
Katrina:  这谁画的
Katrina: Who drew this?
Katrina: a little bit ugly
Katrina: A little bit ugly.
Shure:  你真的你真的
Shure: You really, you really...
Shure:  你现在腿跟腿跟头发一个色的
Shure: Your legs and hair are the same color now.
Shure:  你居然
Shure: You actually...
Katrina:  我居然上脸哎
Katrina: I actually put it on my face.
Shure: 真的上脸
Shure: Really on your face.
Katrina: 以后就跟领导说酒精过敏
Katrina: From now on, just tell the boss you're allergic to alcohol.
Katrina: 喝不了酒
Katrina: Can't drink.
Shure: 啊酒精过敏喝不了酒
Shure: Yeah, allergic to alcohol, can't drink.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你特像那小学生
Katrina: You totally look like that elementary school kid.
Katrina:  我们班上的男生
Katrina: The boys in our class.
Shure: 啊酒精过敏喝不了酒
Shure: Yeah, allergic to alcohol, can't drink.
Katrina: 打扫卫生
Katrina: Clean up.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 我们上去打扫卫生去
Shure: Let's go upstairs to clean.
Shure:  快把你的斧根喝掉
Shure: Hurry and finish your Fu Gen drink.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  喝完就打一套醉拳
Katrina: I'll do some drunken boxing after I finish.
Shure:  什么打电话去
Shure: What? Make a phone call?
Katrina: 打一套醉拳呐
Katrina: Do some drunken boxing.
Katrina:  啊被倒掉了
Katrina: Oh, it got dumped out.
Shure:  完了你的斧根被倒掉了
Shure: Oh no, your Fu Gen got dumped out.
Shure:  也没有斧了
Shure: There's no axe either.
Katrina:  太好了哇菜刀
Katrina: Great, a kitchen knife!
Shure: 比划两下
Shure: Let me show you a few moves.
Katrina:  给你舞一个
Katrina: I'll dance with it for you.
Katrina:  自己刀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: My own knife, haha.
Katrina:  这油倒哪呢
Katrina: Where should I pour this oil?
Tasha: 那
Tasha: There.
Shure:  为什么拿他晒
Shure: Why is he sunbathing with it?
Shure:  给你倒的酒你没有喝
Shure: You didn't drink the wine I poured for you.
Tasha: 我喝了
Tasha: I did drink it.
Shure:  喝了那一捏捏算啊
Shure: Drinking just a little pinch counts?
Tasha:一捏捏我靠
Tasha: A little pinch, come on.
Tasha: 你好会扭哦
Tasha: You're so good at twisting.
Katrina:  倒倒倒哪来的
Katrina: Pour, pour, where did this come from?
Shure:  我来倒吧
Shure: Let me pour it.
Shure:  我来倒我来倒
Shure: I'll pour it, I'll pour it.
Katrina:  倒麻酱里
Katrina: Pour it into the sesame paste.
Tasha: 对先倒到这吧
Tasha: Yeah, pour it here first.
Katrina:  小时候我给老鼠做老鼠药就这样
Katrina: When I was a kid, I made rat poison like this.
Shure:  还做这个呢
Shure: You made that too?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Wow.
Katrina: 风油精花露水
Katrina: Essential balm and floral water.
Katrina:  加一点好吃的饼干
Katrina: Add some tasty biscuits.
Katrina:  哎我看有没有那个塑料袋
Katrina: Hey, let me see if there's a plastic bag.
Katrina:  我们直接扔了
Katrina: We'll just throw it away.
Shure:  你觉得我
Shure: Do you think I...
Shure:  我明天这瓶我觉得就可以喝完了你知道吧
Shure: I think I can finish this bottle by tomorrow, you know?
Katrina:  哈哈哈再说你你就这样拿
Katrina: Haha, you say that, but you just hold it like this.
Katrina:  我们给你拍个海报
Katrina: We'll take a poster for you.
Katrina:  就那天迎宾的时候
Katrina: Like when we were welcoming guests that day.
Shure: 我从小喝到大
Shure: I've been drinking it since I was a kid.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh my.
Katrina:  噢我有泸溪河的
Katrina: Oh, I have a Luxi River one.
Katrina: 泸溪河的袋子
Katrina: A Luxi River bag.
Shure:  泸溪河
Shure: Luxi River.
Shure: 我给你们俩加油
Shure: I'll cheer for you two.
Shure: 加油加油加油
Shure: Go, go, go!
Jake: 来您您来一起加加油吧
Jake: Come on, let's cheer together.
Jake: 要不
Jake: Or else...
Shure: 加油加油加油加油加油
Shure: Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Tasha: 您就把这个
Tasha: You just need to...
Shure: 我不听加油加油加油我不听
Shure: I'm not listening, come on, come on, I'm not listening.
Shure:  加油加油哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, come on, hahaha.
Katrina:  你今天晚上任务是负责把
Katrina: Your task tonight is to...
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: Yes, OK.
Katrina:  学会明天教我们
Katrina: Learn it and teach us tomorrow.
Shure:  我我我今天晚上负负责喝的死死的
Shure: I, I, I am responsible for drinking a lot tonight.
Shure:  然后睡觉
Shure: Then sleep.
Katrina:  Lucy和儿子太像了呀
Katrina: Lucia and her son look so alike.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  酒精大学四年怎么过来的
Shure: How did I get through four years of college with alcohol?
Katrina:  哎苦学生
Katrina: Oh, poor student.
Katrina:  嘘又被我撞到了
Katrina: Shh, I bumped into it again.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Shure: 嘘
Shure: Shh.
Katrina:  大学四年都干什么啊
Katrina: What did you do in those four years of college?
Katrina:  忘了感觉保研之后才真正大学生活
Katrina: I forgot, it feels like real college life started after I got my recommendation.
Katrina:  但是我感觉我也没有那种特别
Katrina: But I feel like I didn't have that kind of...
Katrina:  就是学的特别吓人的那种
Katrina: like studying insanely hard.
Katrina:  就是期末周去那种
Katrina: Just during final exam week.
Katrina:  主要我们班
Katrina: Mainly our class...
Katrina:  我们班保研率很高保40%
Katrina: Our class had a high recommendation rate, 40%.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina:  然后运气特别好
Katrina: Then we were very lucky.
Katrina:  然后一般就是我们年级这个实验班
Katrina: Usually, in our grade, the experimental class...
Katrina:  他是需要竞争
Katrina: You needed to compete.
Katrina:  大一分流的时候竞争进去
Katrina: Compete to get in during freshman year.
Katrina:  然后我们那一年
Katrina: And that year...
Katrina:  我们那一年没人报你知道吗
Katrina: No one applied that year, you know?
Katrina:  然后我绩点那么低我都进了
Katrina: My GPA was so low, but I still got in.
Katrina:  然后我就保研了
Katrina: Then I got the recommendation.
Alice: 这俩是谁的
Alice: Whose are these two?
Alice:还喝吗
Alice: Still drinking?
Katrina:  我人生很搞笑的我感觉
Katrina: I feel like my life is so funny.
Shure:  东北孩子都会唱刀郎
Shure: Every kid from the Northeast can sing Daolang.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 好恶心
Shure: So disgusting.
Shure:  这都是你吃的东西你好恶心
Shure: This is all the stuff you ate, so gross.
Katrina:  麻酱no
Katrina: Sesame sauce no.
Shure:  麻酱no
Shure: Sesame sauce no.
Katrina: yes no
Katrina: Yes no.
Shure:  然后醋yes是吗
Shure: And vinegar, yes, right?
Katrina:  狂加醋
Katrina: Add lots of vinegar.
Jake: 嘿，露西亚呢
Jake: Hey, where's Luya?
Shure:  露西亚已经睡着了吧
Shure: Luya's probably asleep.
Shure:  可能
Shure: Maybe.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:露西亚带个眼镜呗
Jake: Luya, put on your glasses.
Katrina: 她喝酒了吗
Katrina: Did she drink?
Shure:  他喝了一碗
Shure: He drank a bowl.
Jake: 一碗
Jake: A bowl?
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: Oh no.
Shure:  我们要不晚上再来一局吧
Shure: How about we play another round tonight?
Katrina:  哈哈晚上再来一局
Katrina: Haha, play another round tonight.
Katrina:  就直接给你掏心掏肺讲故事了
Katrina: You'll just pour your heart out telling stories.
Shure:  哈哈哈我就要听掏心掏肺讲故事哎
Shure: Haha, I want to hear heartfelt stories.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure:  其实其实酒桌上掏心掏肺讲故事
Shure: Actually, when you pour your heart out at the drinking table,
Shure:  第二天第二另另外几个人都记不住
Shure: the next day, the others won't remember.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  你掏心掏肺讲完了你你很爽
Shure: You pour your heart out, you feel great.
Shure:  然后其他人也很爽
Shure: And everyone else feels great.
Shure:  但是大家都记不住这个事
Shure: But no one remembers what happened.
Shure:  情就很很很爽
Shure: It's just a great feeling.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina:  对爽了就行
Katrina: Yeah, as long as it feels good.
Shure:  这大家只走一个过程
Shure: It's all about the experience.
Katrina:  真好呀主要我当时我舍友都特别乖
Katrina: That's nice. My roommates were all so well-behaved back then.
Katrina:  没人提议说去酒吧
Katrina: No one suggested going to a bar.
Shure:  也不一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: You don't always have to go to a bar.
Shure:  谁喝酒一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: Who says you have to go to a bar to drink?
Katrina:  喝一瓶RIO就倒了
Katrina: Just one bottle of RIO and they were out.
Katrina: crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Jake: 这边都不够
Jake: This isn't enough.
Jake: 要不带点下去洗
Jake: Maybe take some downstairs to wash.
Jake: 再带一个
Jake: Take another one.
Jake: 碗下去洗吧要不
Jake: Take the bowl downstairs to wash, maybe?
Jake: 这边够了
Jake: This is enough here.
Shure:  加油加油加油加油加
Shure: Come on, come on, come on, come on!
Katrina: 你跳那个
Katrina: Jump like that
Katrina:  cheer baby
Katrina: Cheer baby
Katrina: 你听过twice那歌没有
Katrina: Have you heard that song by Twice?
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Choiszt: 呃等会你先别扔
Choiszt: Uh, wait a minute, don't throw it yet.
Katrina: twice的那个歌
Katrina: That song by Twice.
Shure: 你教我
Shure: Teach me.
Katrina:  他有一首歌叫cheer cheer up就很元气
Katrina: They have a song called "Cheer Cheer Up," it's really energetic.
Katrina:  什么cheerbaby
Katrina: What "cheer baby"?
Katrina:  就是他们在干家务的时候
Katrina: It's like when they're doing housework,
Katrina:  你就在旁边cheer
Katrina: You just cheer on the side.
Katrina:  babycheer
Katrina: Baby cheer.
Katrina:  baby
Katrina: Baby.
Shure: 我还会跳这种什么
Shure: I can also dance this kind of thing?
Shure:  啊你也会跳这个是吗
Shure: Ah, you can also dance this, right?
Katrina:  会啊高中的时候不是可流行的吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was so popular back in high school.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  杨老板会跳这个吗
Shure: Can Jake dance this?
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Shure:  这这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure: 好东西
Shure: Good stuff.
Jake: 哦会跳这个
Jake: Oh, I can dance this.
Jake: 因为我我以前
Jake: Because I, I used to...
Jake: 我在美国那个房东的小孩
Jake: My landlord's kid in America
Jake: 就天天在我面前秀这个
Jake: Would show me this every day.
Tasha: 这个水是用这个是洗不掉的
Tasha: This water can't wash this off.
Jake: 那用什么
Jake: Then what do we use?
Shure:  看杨老板也不一般
Shure: Look, Jake isn't ordinary either.
Katrina:  也年轻过
Katrina: He was young once too.
Shure:  也年轻过
Shure: He was young once too.
Shure:  谁没年轻过呢是吧
Shure: Who hasn't been young, right?
Choiszt: 你们这些袋要扔吗现在
Choiszt: Are you guys throwing these bags away now?
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Should we?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Choiszt: 带个手套吧
Choiszt: Put on some gloves.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你要把它装进来
Tasha: Oh, I thought you wanted to pack it up.
Katrina:  你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look at me standing here,
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What
Katrina: 你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look, I'm standing here
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while
Shure:  哲学你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand philosophy?
Shure:  他虽然就是形态站在这
Shure: Even though he's standing here physically
Shure:  但是意识已经走了
Shure: His mind has already left
Nicous: 绝对有点喝多了
Nicous: He's definitely had too much to drink
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 不要紧
Shure: It's fine
Tasha: 这还有个男呃好吧他走了
Tasha: There's a guy... oh, he's gone
Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Time for a drinking test to start
Katrina:  这怎么洗呢
Katrina: How do we clean this?
Katrina:  能拿厨房湿巾吗
Katrina: Can we use kitchen wipes?
Jake: 这要不放下面洗
Jake: How about we wash it downstairs
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Just wash it here
Tasha: 你可以换一张抹布了
Tasha: You can use a different cloth
Lucia: 更方便洗一些
Lucia: It'd be easier to clean
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It's still usable
Lucia: 这能先擦一遍吗
Lucia: Can we wipe it first?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This
Tasha: 这个不用待会直接洗洁精洗就行了
Tasha: You can just use dish soap later
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Ah, that works too
Lucia: 感觉里面很多渣
Lucia: Feels like there's a lot of residue inside
Lucia: 有的把它先弄出来
Lucia: Let's get it out first
Lucia: 刚那个不是有点
Lucia: Wasn't there a bit of
Lucia: 稍微有点
Lucia: Slightly
Lucia: 那个啥有点堵
Lucia: It was a bit clogged
Tasha: 喝一口啊
Tasha: Have a sip
Tasha: 这汤好鲜美啊
Tasha: This soup is so delicious
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: You sure
Shure:  我给你们打call
Shure: I'll cheer for you guys
Jake: 你说的真的
Jake: If you say it's good
Jake: 那就是真的
Jake: Then it must be good
Katrina:  你喝什么呢
Katrina: What are you drinking?
Shure:  啤啤酒
Shure: Beer
Shure:  尝一尝吧
Shure: Give it a try
Katrina:  不要了
Katrina: No, thanks
Shure: 尝尝吧
Shure: Try it.
Nicous: 我马上把这些录下来
Nicous: I'll record this right away.
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈你他妈的
Shure: Haha, you son of a...
Katrina: 当心
Katrina: Be careful.
Tasha: 我帮你扔掉
Tasha: I'll throw it away for you.
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thank you!
Shure:  不是我怎么了
Shure: It's not me, what happened?
Lucia: 对擦了擦感觉掉不了
Lucia: Yeah, wiped it, but it won't come off.
Lucia: 不管他那个了
Lucia: Never mind that.
Shure:  欠你妈
Shure: Damn you.
Tasha: 这个锅原来在二楼吗
Tasha: Was this pot originally on the second floor?
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: This pot?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也我也不太确定
Lucia: I'm not too sure either.
Lucia: 我也不太确定
Lucia: I'm not too sure.
Nicous: 都躺在一起睡了个觉
Nicous: All lying down together for a nap.
Shure:  你他妈有病吧再说一句
Shure: Are you freaking crazy? Say that again.
Shure: 你不要瞎说好吗
Shure: Don't talk nonsense, okay?
Nicous: 啊孩子绝对信你
Nicous: Ah, the kid will totally believe you.
Shure:  我觉得
Shure: I think...
Shure:  是时候拿出吉他了
Shure: It's time to bring out the guitar.
Shure:  窗
Shure: Window.
Nicous: 也给你找个草坪
Nicous: I'll find you a lawn too.
Shure:  找草坪干嘛
Shure: Why a lawn?
Tasha: 嗯放这吧
Tasha: Yeah, put it here.
Shure:  那不是帅老师用的洗手间吗
Shure: Isn't that the restroom Choiszt uses?
Shure:  洗手间
Shure: Restroom.
Shure:  帅老师不喜欢回归大自然吗
Shure: Doesn't Choiszt like to return to nature?
Alice: 这谁的呀
Alice: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I didn't finish it.
Alice: 那我给你留这了啊
Alice: I'll leave it here for you then.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Shure: 给你留这
Shure: Leaving it for you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking it?
Shure:  你喝吗
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I'm drinking it.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Really drinking it?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Really drinking it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: You should be fine with one drink, right?
Shure:  喝一杯他
Shure: One drink won't matter
Shure:  他毫无关系
Shure: It doesn't matter at all
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Nicous: 你要不等那个拍完再喝
Nicous: Why don't you wait until after the shoot to drink?
Nicous: 忍一下
Nicous: Hold on a bit
Nicous: 因为他不可控
Nicous: Because it's uncontrollable
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: The vinegar is down there
Shure:  我觉得就要给AI加一些不可控因素
Shure: I think we should add some uncontrollable factors to the AI
Shure:  没事这这这柜里还有3瓶呢
Shure: No worries, there are still 3 bottles in the cabinet
Tasha: 可以竖着放
Tasha: You can put it upright
Lucia: 啊对不起对不起啊
Lucia: Ah, sorry, sorry
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia: 刚那个有点使劲好像水崩起来了
Lucia: I think I used too much force, water splashed up
Lucia: 没有溅到你们身上吧
Lucia: Did it splash on you guys?
Shure: 什么那个2002年的第一场雪
Shure: What about that song "The First Snow in 2002"
Shure: 这每个每个东北孩子都会唱的我跟你讲
Shure: Every kid from the Northeast can sing it, I'm telling you
Jake: 好油啊
Jake: So oily
Tasha: 没关系这只是洗第一
Tasha: It's okay, this is just the first wash
Tasha: 遍还有洗第二遍的
Tasha: There's still the second wash
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it
Tasha: 好油啊
Tasha: So oily
Lucia: 台子旁边
Lucia: Next to the counter
Tasha: 原本是很干净的杯子
Tasha: It was a clean cup originally
Tasha: 你把它放到油碗里
Tasha: You put it in the oil bowl
Tasha: 好油呀他变的呵呵
Tasha: So oily, it changed, haha
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Let's buy a small dishwasher
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Is there any more trash?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: Another round
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more
Alice: 没了
Alice: No more
Shure:  硕什么
Shure: What Shure?
Lucia: 因为里面扔了很多
Lucia: Because a lot was thrown in there
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up bro
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to buy a dishwasher
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: I told you to be the dishwasher
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: Make you a dishwasher.
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: Let me buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying one is tough.
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: Make you a dishwasher.
Shure: 什么买个洗碗机
Shure: What, buy a dishwasher?
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher.
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Damn, buy a dishwasher.
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really, bro?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, did you notice? You need to clean it.
Shure: bro
Shure: Bro.
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed.
Lucia: 那我把这拿下去
Lucia: I'll take this down.
Tasha: 真有水平
Tasha: Really impressive.
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: Like they weren't washed at all.
Tasha: 你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at these chopsticks.
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: They're in two clumps now.
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  服了呀
Shure: I'm done.
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I can't take it anymore.
Shure:  一看就是在家
Shure: Clearly at home...
Shure:  一天天娇生惯养的孩子们
Shure: Kids spoiled at home every day.
Jake: 可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jake: 谁在家呢
Jake: Who's at home?
Shure:  请问在在Singapore
Shure: Please, in Singapore...
Shure:  娇生惯养的孩子
Shure: Spoiled kids.
Jake: 那也没在在Singapore也不在家待着
Jake: Even in Singapore, they're not staying at home.
Shure:  哎我搅一会吧
Shure: Let me stir it for a bit.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Then let the water drain.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this first?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: You can put it anywhere.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: I'll stir it for a while.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll go wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: Oh, it's so frustrating.
Lucia: 这这袋子先放这扔垃圾了
Lucia: I'll leave this bag here for now, throw it away later.
Lucia: 扔满了再拿下去
Lucia: Throw it away when it's full.
Tasha: 这油的
Tasha: It's greasy.
Shure:  哎呦我搅一下
Shure: Oh, let me stir it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈洗碗机成功
Tasha: Haha, dishwasher success.
Shure:  ai看到了吗
Shure: Hey, did you see that?
Shure:  就是人类搅一圈之后
Shure: After people stir it around,
Shure:  手上会有这么多油
Shure: their hands get this oily.
Shure:  你记住了吗
Shure: Got it?
Shure: 跟你讲究侮
Shure: I'm telling you,
Shure:  侮辱杨老板的数据石吧
Shure: you're messing with Jake's data, right?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 这越洗越油
Tasha: The more you wash, the oilier it gets.
Tasha: 不要用另一只手摸他了
Tasha: Stop touching it with the other hand.
Tasha: 你拿那个湿巾擦一下
Tasha: Use a wet wipe to clean it off.
Lucia: 可以去油应该
Lucia: That should remove the oil.
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Alice: 这洗好了吗
Alice: Is it clean now?
Tasha: 这还要再冲一遍呢
Tasha: It needs another rinse.
Tasha: 这只用洗洁精抹了一遍
Tasha: I just washed it once with detergent.
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Alice: 刚洗的手
Alice: Just washed hands.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then,
Shure: 您是这个
Shure: you are this...
Shure: 对然后随便找个袋
Shure: Yeah, then just find a bag.
Shure: 然后然后然后我倒下去
Shure: And then, and then, I'll pour it in.
Tasha: 你经常干这个活啊
Tasha: Do you do this often?
Shure: 我哎
Shure: I...
Tasha: 把里面的渣渣能不能捞出来
Tasha: Can you fish out the residue inside?
Shure:  一遍一遍冲进去就好了
Shure: Just rinse it again and again.
Tasha: 倒也不用这么干净吧我觉得
Tasha: I don't think it needs to be that clean.
Shure:  咱咱咱得过四五天呢哥
Shure: We got four or five days, buddy.
Tasha: 要不以后别用楼上的厨房了哈哈哈哈
Tasha: How about we stop using the upstairs kitchen, hahaha.
Shure: 要不以后别用厨房了都点外卖了
Shure: How about we stop using the kitchen altogether and just order takeout?
Shure: 咱买一次性的锅
Shure: Let's get disposable pots.
Tasha: 还有一次性的锅这种说
Tasha: There's such a thing as disposable pots?
Shure:  有那锡纸锅两块钱一个哈哈
Shure: Yeah, those foil pots, two bucks each, haha.
Shure:  卧槽真的
Shure: Really.
Tasha: 你就是专业干这个的呀
Tasha: You must be a pro at this.
Tasha: 怪不得喊你来当洗碗机呢
Tasha: No wonder they call you the dishwasher.
Lucia: 这边我觉得还是
Lucia: Over here, I think still...
Tasha: 需要帮忙吗
Tasha: Need any help?
Lucia: 等过会擦吧
Lucia: We'll wipe it later.
Lucia: 这太高了吧
Lucia: This is too high, right?
Lucia: 放下来一点
Lucia: Lower it a bit.
Tasha: 这个还要再冲一遍了
Tasha: This needs to be rinsed again.
Alice: 你手串是开过光的吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Alice: 你那手串开过光吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Shure:  没有女朋友随便送我的
Shure: No, my ex-girlfriend casually gave it to me.
Tasha: 肯定是他不要的哈哈哈
Tasha: It must be something he didn't want, haha.
Shure:  我就你会说话是不是
Shure: You just love talking, don't you?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  你信不信我这这盘子抡你脑袋上
Shure: Do you believe I'll smash this plate on your head?
Tasha: 你说随便送东西的
Tasha: You said it was casually given.
Tasha: 肯定是她淘汰下来的货
Tasha: It must be something she discarded.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  因为我平时平时穿粉色衣服多
Shure: Because I usually wear a lot of pink clothes.
Shure:  然后送我一个粉色手串
Shure: So she gave me a pink bracelet.
Tasha: 哦你早说嘛
Tasha: Oh, you should've said so earlier.
Tasha: 是她特地送给你的不就行了
Tasha: It's specially given to you, right?
Tasha: 你为什么说是随便送给你的
Tasha: Why did you say it was casually given?
Shure:  我他妈
Shure: Damn it.
Alice: 要轻描淡写过去这个话题哈哈哈
Alice: Just gloss over this topic, haha.
Tasha: 然后还说要打我
Tasha: And then you said you'd hit me.
Lucia: 好像嗯我把这个扔了吧
Lucia: Seems like I should throw this away.
Lucia: 在站一会没抓到什么可以擦的东西
Lucia: Been standing here and can't find anything to wipe.
Shure:  把杯子先都刷出来了
Shure: Wash all the cups first.
Shure:  因为杯子啊
Shure: Because the cups...
Shure:  啊对于喝酒
Shure: For drinking, they're important, so wash them all.
Shure:  来说很重要所以要都刷出来
Lucia: 这没杯子吗
Lucia: Aren't there any cups?
Shure:  这本来就有杯子
Shure: There were cups originally.
Shure:  咱们都使完了你知道吗
Shure: We used them all, you know?
Lucia: 不是我是说
Lucia: No, I mean...
Lucia: 就是我没看到有刷完需要擦的杯子
Lucia: I didn't see any cups that needed wiping.
Lucia: 就是你这不是正刷着吗
Lucia: You're washing them right now, aren't you?
Shure:  行了我刷了我刷了哎呦卧槽
Shure: Alright, I'll wash them, I'll wash them. Oh, damn.
Shure:  哎呦呦呦呦
Shure: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure:  帮我拿点谢谢
Shure: Help me out a bit, thanks.
Shure:  愁死了
Shure: This is so frustrating.
Shure:  什什么喝完酒还要刷杯子呀
Shure: What? We have to wash cups after drinking?
Shure:  卧槽这是
Shure: Damn, this is...
Alice: 啊这还有俩锅
Alice: Oh, there are two more pots.
Shure:  杨老板给我结double工资
Shure: Jake, give me double salary.
Shure:  不然话我不干了杨老板
Shure: Or else I quit, Jake.
Tasha: 这可不是你能决定的
Tasha: That's not up to you.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我把这碗拿下拿到楼下刷一下算了
Lucia: I'll take this bowl downstairs and wash it.
Shure:  这碗不是刷完的吗
Shure: Wasn't this bowl already washed?
Lucia: 不是要再涮一遍吗
Lucia: Doesn't it need another rinse?
Tasha: 再冲一遍就行了
Tasha: Just rinse it one more time.
Shure: 你哎
Shure: You...
Tasha: 拿下去
Tasha: Take it down.
Shure:  哎再再给我用一下
Shure: Hey, let me use it again.
Shure:  还有还有两个
Shure: There are still two more.
Shure:  OKOK
Shure: OK, OK.
Choiszt:  不要了
Choiszt: No need.
Shure: 不要了
Shure: No need.
Choiszt: 这就直接一擦就干净
Choiszt: Just a wipe and it's clean.
Alice: 有点难受了
Alice: Feeling a bit uncomfortable.
Alice: 热热的
Alice: It's hot.
Tasha: 不知道明天干嘛
Tasha: No idea what to do tomorrow.
Katrina:  明天干嘛
Katrina: What's the plan for tomorrow?
Katrina:  我要写小本了
Katrina: I need to write my to-do list.
Katrina:  to do list
Katrina: To do list.
Alice: 我能不能看着搓啊
Alice: Can I just watch?
Tasha: 看着搓什么意思
Tasha: Watch what?
Alice:就看着别人打
Alice: Just watch others play.
Tasha: 也可以呢
Tasha: Sure.
Alice:凑够四个人很简单的吧应该吧
Alice: It should be easy to gather four people, right?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: Probably.
Katrina:  现在是期中考试月
Katrina: It's midterm exam month now.
Shure:  你们还有期中考试吗
Shure: You still have midterms?
Katrina:  没有看我学弟他们发的朋友圈
Katrina: No, I saw my juniors posting on social media.
Katrina:  他们在痛苦我在快乐
Katrina: They're suffering, I'm enjoying.
Shure:  都多大了还还期中考试呢
Shure: How old are you and still have midterms?
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝宝
Katrina: I'm a good student who loves studying.
Shure:  你是一个爱学习的人
Shure: You're someone who loves studying.
Katrina:  哈哈哈气死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, you're killing me.
Shure:  我是一个爱学习的人
Shure: I'm someone who loves studying.
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝
Katrina: I'm a good student who loves studying.
Katrina:  整点music
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Shure: like study
Shure: Like study.
Shure:  什么什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: When are you going to clean the room?
Shure:  快扫房间
Shure: Hurry up and clean the room.
Shure:  然后把这个眼镜摘了
Shure: And then take off these glasses.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  同意
Katrina: I agree.
Shure:  哎呦我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Katrina:  噢不对吹一下
Katrina: Oh no, blow it.
Katrina:  听过这个卢广冢的歌吗
Katrina: Have you ever listened to a song by Lu Guangzhong?
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina:  谁卢广冢
Katrina: Who is Lu Guangzhong?
Shure:  听过
Shure: I've heard of him.
Katrina:  哎哎我这平板那个音效特好
Katrina: Hey, my tablet has great sound effects.
Katrina:  4个
Katrina: Four of them.
Katrina: 买来听歌
Katrina: I bought it to listen to music.
Katrina:  学习一点没干
Katrina: Didn't do any studying at all.
Lucia: 哎这从
Lucia: Hey, from here...
Lucia: 哦这从有抹布
Lucia: Oh, there's a cloth here.
Katrina:  我靠跟音响一样
Katrina: Wow, it sounds like a speaker.
Shure:  走去楼下听去
Shure: Let's go downstairs to listen.
Katrina:  楼下咋了
Katrina: What's up with downstairs?
Katrina:  PK一下你的音响跟我的平板吗
Katrina: Are we going to compare your speaker with my tablet?
Shure:  开玩笑那两个独立单元跟你这个比
Shure: Are you kidding? Those two separate units compared to yours?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我这一个这一个
Katrina: Haha, I only have one, this one.
Shure:  喝点嘛喝点嘛
Shure: Drink some, drink some.
Katrina:  又想套我话是不是哈哈哈
Katrina: Are you trying to get me to talk again, huh? Haha.
Shure:  喝点喝点来来来
Shure: Drink some, come on, come on.
Katrina: 不
Katrina: No.
Shure: 什么对
Shure: What do you mean, no?
Katrina:  今天晚上还有东西要干呢
Katrina: I still have things to do tonight.
Shure:  我24号交毕设
Shure: I have to submit my thesis on the 24th.
Shure:  你几号交毕设
Shure: When do you have to submit yours?
Katrina:  你论文写完了吗
Katrina: Have you finished your paper?
Shure:  写差不多了
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina:  呀怎么切了呀给我
Katrina: Oh no, it got cut off, give it to me.
Katrina:  这什么老歌
Katrina: What's this old song?
Katrina:  林志炫的
Katrina: It's by Terry Lin.
Katrina:  我要去把楼下那个to do list写一下
Katrina: I need to go write the to-do list downstairs.
Shure:  to do list是吗
Shure: The to-do list, right?
Katrina:  明天
Katrina: For tomorrow.
Lucia: 我靠嘞
Lucia: Oh my god.
Katrina:  成为一个自带BGM的女生
Katrina: Become a girl with her own background music.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  却又消失不见
Katrina: But then disappear again.
Katrina:  明天干什么呀
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we cleaning the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Katrina: 明天干什么
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天
Jake: Tomorrow...
Shure:  扫房间扫房间扫房间
Shure: Clean the room, clean the room, clean the room.
Nicous: 这是哪一个
Nicous: Which one is this?
Jake:今晚扫一遍明天扫一遍现在就开始
Jake: Clean once tonight, clean once tomorrow, let's start now.
Jake: 收拾完就开始扫
Jake: Start cleaning after tidying up.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 然后那个交换礼物
Jake: And then the gift exchange.
Shure:  你告诉我这是什么我给你放
Shure: Tell me what it is and I'll play it.
Katrina:  卢广仲的歌
Katrina: Lu Guangzhong's song.
Katrina:  明天干啥嘞
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天干啥嘞
Jake: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake: 明天室外吧
Jake: Let's do something outdoors tomorrow.
Shure:  我们明天去
Shure: We're going...
Shure:  KTV吧
Shure: To KTV, right?
Jake:可拉倒吧
Jake: No way.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这附近好像有一个最近的公园
Katrina: There's a nearby park, I think.
Katrina:  是两三公里
Katrina: It's like two or three kilometers away.
Katrina:  你要去公园吗
Katrina: Do you want to go to the park?
Jake: 可以去采一采景拍拍东西
Jake: We can go check out the scenery and take some pictures.
Jake: 然后最后一天放
Jake: And then show them on the last day.
Katrina:  什么最后一天放
Katrina: What do you mean by the last day?
Jake:放放放影片
Jake: Show the videos.
Katrina:  最后一天放影片
Katrina: Show the videos on the last day?
Jake: 对这个采采风吧
Jake: Yeah, let's collect some shots.
Katrina:  就是明天户外是吧
Katrina: So, tomorrow is outdoor, right?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, outdoor tomorrow.
Jake: 采采风
Jake: Capture some scenes.
Katrina:  笑呀笑
Katrina: Laugh, laugh.
Jake: 明天主要是等快递啊
Jake: Mainly waiting for the delivery tomorrow.
Katrina:  啊快递有好多才今天下的
Katrina: Oh, there are a lot of deliveries just placed today.
Jake: 对明天
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow.
Jake: 明天等快递
Jake: Waiting for deliveries tomorrow.
Jake: 在路上后天你们快递
Jake: Your package will arrive the day after tomorrow.
Shure: 这首歌叫什么
Shure: What's this song called?
Jake: 到了才能再setup吧
Jake: We'll set it up once it arrives.
Nicous: 就像那个叫什么唱那个
Nicous: It's like, what's the name of that song...
Katrina:  其实其实快递的集中应该是在后天到
Katrina: Actually, the packages should arrive the day after tomorrow.
Katrina: 比较多明天还好
Katrina: There will be more the day after tomorrow, tomorrow is fine.
Katrina:  你买时钟了吗
Katrina: Did you buy a clock?
Choiszt: 这首歌叫啥
Choiszt: What's this song called?
Katrina:  我爱你卢广仲的对
Katrina: It's "I Love You" by Crowd Lu, right.
Katrina:  那明天就一个户外
Katrina: So tomorrow will be outdoors.
Katrina:  不允许这么宽泛的存在
Katrina: No such broad existence is allowed.
Katrina:  你们当时那个表呢
Katrina: Where's that watch you had back then?
Katrina:  太阳公公出来了
Katrina: Mr. Sun is out.
Katrina:  你居然
Katrina: You actually...
Katrina:  好吧略胜一筹啊
Katrina: Alright, you won by a bit.
Shure:  哈哈哈这叫略胜吗
Shure: Hahaha, you call that winning by a bit?
Shure:  哈哈哈碾压
Shure: Hahaha, that's crushing it.
Katrina:  他说我的那个平板音响跟他的那个
Katrina: He said my tablet speaker compared to his...
Katrina:  开外挂
Katrina: Cheating.
Katrina:  一下猥琐了起来
Katrina: Suddenly became so sneaky.
Katrina:  美纹纸
Katrina: Masking tape.
Shure:  好好久没喝这么多了
Shure: Wow, haven't drunk this much in a while.
Nicous:  这明显喝多了
Nicous: It's obvious you've had too much.
Katrina: 我必须要看一下
Katrina: I need to take a look.
Shure:  呵j人
Shure: Haha
Shure:  就是要看一下明天去哪个地方是吧
Shure: You mean you need to check where to go tomorrow, right?
Katrina:  对呀不然明天再决定去哪个地方的时候
Katrina: Yeah, otherwise, if we decide where to go tomorrow,
Katrina:  又会耽误半个小时在那决定
Katrina: we'll waste another half an hour deciding.
Shure: 随机去哪个地方就好了
Shure: We can just go somewhere randomly.
Katrina: 得去公园吧
Katrina: We should go to the park.
Shure: 我们去环球
Shure: Let's go to Universal.
Katrina:  什么时候买新衣服啊
Katrina: When are we buying new clothes?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina:  我跟我舍友说话
Katrina: I was talking to my roommate.
Katrina:  他们背着我逛街去了
Katrina: They went shopping without me.
Katrina:  来
Katrina: Come here.
Katrina:  我来教你
Katrina: Let me teach you.
Nicous:  这是买第三代这个
Nicous: This is the third generation one.
Katrina: 嗯其实嗯
Katrina: Yeah, actually...
Katrina: 买对买这种细的
Katrina: Buy the thin one.
Nicous:  不为什么这49这个90啊
Nicous: Why is this one 49 and that one 90?
Katrina:  本来就这样啊
Katrina: That's just how it is.
Katrina:  得物会贵一点
Katrina: Items on Dewu are more expensive.
Katrina:  然后你那个还要加税费呢
Katrina: And you also need to add tax.
Nicous: 这个是吧
Nicous: This one, right?
Katrina:  对应该是还要加几块钱税费的十几块钱税费差不多60
Katrina: Yeah, there should be a few dollars in taxes, around ten dollars, making it about 60.
Katrina:  本来代购就便宜
Katrina: Purchasing agents are cheaper.
Katrina:  因为那个得物他要收手续费
Katrina: Because Dewu charges service fees.
Katrina:  好男人
Katrina: Good man.
Jake: 啥呀这是
Jake: What's this?
Katrina:  给他女朋友买礼物挑的头疼
Katrina: He's having a hard time picking a gift for his girlfriend.
Jake: 你你怎么了
Jake: What happened to you?
Jake: 你你女朋友怎么了
Jake: What happened to your girlfriend?
Katrina:  没怎么
Katrina: Nothing.
Katrina:  就是一个平板
Katrina: It's just a tablet.
Katrina:  就是一个开心
Katrina: Just something to make her happy.
Jake:我要我要开扫了
Jake: I'm going to start scanning.
Jake: 要不我先扫下面
Jake: Should I scan the bottom first?
Shure: 快扫快扫
Shure: Hurry up and scan.
Jake: 上去吧
Jake: Go upstairs.
Shure: 为什么叫上去
Shure: Why do you call it going upstairs?
Jake:你们你们得上去
Jake: You guys need to go up.
Shure:  哦好好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Choiszt:  需要人手吗
Choiszt: Do you need a hand?
Jake: 这个不需要人手
Jake: No, this doesn't need any help.
Shure:  不需要人是空的需要你没有人
Shure: If it doesn't need anyone, then it's empty and you don't need anyone.
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: Do you get it?
Shure: 向右转
Shure: Turn right.
Shure: 齐步走
Shure: March.
Katrina: 一二一
Katrina: One, two, one.
Katrina: 这是灯吗
Katrina: Is this a lamp?
Katrina:  居然不扫我的房间我房间早收拾好了
Katrina: You're not even cleaning my room. My room has been ready for a while.
Shure:  立定
Shure: Halt.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  爽啊这生活过100年
Katrina: This life is so enjoyable, I could live like this for 100 years.
Shure:  哎我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  真他妈爽卧槽
Shure: This is so freaking awesome.
Shure:  我充电宝把这个榨干了已经
Shure: My power bank is completely drained now.
Shure:  不停期待着明天
Shure: Constantly looking forward to tomorrow.
Shure:  变成了昨天
Shure: But it turns into yesterday.
Katrina: 通州区
Katrina: Tongzhou District.
Shure:  现在就在通州
Shure: We're in Tongzhou right now.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 小红书上看一看有什么公园啊
Shure: Let's check on Xiaohongshu for any parks around.
Katrina:  通州攻略哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Tongzhou guide, hahaha.
Shure: 通州攻略
Shure: Tongzhou guide.
Katrina: 一天玩遍通州
Katrina: Explore Tongzhou in one day.
Shure:  然后一搜全是环球影城
Shure: And when you search, it's all Universal Studios.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: That's hilarious.
Katrina:  北京通州好玩的地方
Katrina: Fun places in Tongzhou, Beijing.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So for the scanning activity later, is everyone here?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity later, I'll be scanning downstairs.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is that?
Jake: 我下面扫完之后
Jake: After I finish scanning downstairs,
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: um, I'll hide in a room.
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: And then we come find you.
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: And to avoid scanning people,
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: I'll stay inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: Then I'll have Choiszt come down and call you guys.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I can't scan you guys, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Hmm, so you guys also need to hide in a room.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: Just, you need to hide, just hide...
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: You guys should just stay outside.
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Okay, yes, right.
Choiszt: 啥意思一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: What do you mean? After cleaning the first floor, they can all go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: I mean, when I'm going upstairs, I shouldn't see anyone.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: When I'm going upstairs, you should be...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, right.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: And you guys can discuss tomorrow's plans here.
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, I'll tell them to go down and hide well.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yes, you guys...
Katrina: 到外面去哦OK
Katrina: Go outside, okay.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You can also...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Right now, outside is fine too.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: Basically, I shouldn't see anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: You guys discuss...
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: Tomorrow's plans more, more discussions.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: More communication.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: More communication.
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow is basically outdoors.
Jake: 然后加点压花什么的对吧
Jake: And then add some pressed flowers, right?
Katrina:  通州这么大
Katrina: Tongzhou is so big.
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Nicous: 多说话那么简单我就一直跟你说
Nicous: Talking more is simple, I'll just keep talking to you.
Katrina: 来呀
Katrina: Come on.
Shure:  你知道你知道多交流的方式是什么
Shure: Do you know how to communicate more?
Shure:  多喝酒就多
Shure: Drink more and then...
Shure:  交流了哈哈
Shure: Communicate more, haha.
Lucia: 边喝边唠嗑啊
Lucia: Drink and chat.
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 那咱整两盅
Lucia: Let's have a couple of drinks.
Katrina: 浓密延长其实都差不多了
Katrina: Thickness and length are pretty much the same.
Katrina:  真的没有那么大区别的
Katrina: There's really not that much difference.
Katrina: 而且我估计你女朋友也不是很懂就截给你了
Katrina: Besides, I guess your girlfriend doesn't really understand, she just gave it to you.
Shure: 你还想喝吗
Shure: Do you want to drink more?
Lucia: 我看一眼还有些啥
Lucia: Let me see what else is there.
Lucia: 啥呀这是啥
Lucia: What's this, what is this?
Shure:  其实就是
Shure: Actually...
Shure:  刚才把你的橙汁换成了葡萄汁
Shure: Just now, I swapped your orange juice with grape juice.
Shure:  他基本就是只喝了一口而已
Shure: He basically just took a sip.
Lucia: 你不喝了吗
Lucia: You're not drinking anymore?
Tasha: 我不是你可以尝尝啊
Tasha: I'm not, you can try it.
Tasha: 我刚术后一个月内不能喝酒
Tasha: I can't drink alcohol for a month after surgery.
Tasha:但是 我没有忍住然后喝了一点
Tasha: But I couldn't resist and had a little.
Tasha: 然后我慢慢喝就行
Tasha: So I'll just drink slowly.
Lucia: 我喝一下你介意吗
Lucia: Do you mind if I take a sip?
Katrina:  一个是浓密款一个纤长
Katrina: One is volumizing, one is lengthening.
Katrina:  纤长浓密浓巧三个
Katrina: There are three: lengthening, volumizing, and rich.
Lucia: 其实我也不介意但是有的会介意一般会先问一下
Lucia: Actually, I don't mind, but some people do, so it's good to ask first.
Shure: 怎么了怎么了嘛
Shure: What's going on, what's going on?
Lucia: 是像素哎
Lucia: It's the pixels.
Katrina:  还是去公园吧
Katrina: Let's just go to the park.
Katrina:  运河公园5.5公里那还行
Katrina: The canal park is 5.5 kilometers, that's okay.
Lucia: 那这些羊如果你很长时间不管他他会消失吗
Lucia: So if you don't take care of these sheep for a long time, will they disappear?
Tasha: 不会
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 那你不断的点岂不是就会有很多很多的羊
Lucia: So if you keep clicking, won't you have a lot of sheep?
Tasha: 对然后可以跳到水里面
Tasha: Yeah, and they can jump into the water.
Nicous: 我觉得你那个什么SB前男友买错是有道理的
Nicous: I think your dumb ex-boyfriend had a reason for buying the wrong one.
Choiszt:  你们上面稍微稍微收一下因为他一会要自己上来扫
Choiszt: You guys need to clean up a bit because he's going to come up and sweep later.
Choiszt: 还有你的iPad
Choiszt: And your iPad too.
Nicous: 口红都能买错确实太SB了他妈不就是一个数字嘛
Nicous: He even got the lipstick wrong, such an idiot. It's just a number.
Choiszt: 包括那边那个什么遥控器啥的拿一下
Choiszt: Also, grab that remote and stuff from over there.
Shure: 口红买错真的太SB了
Shure: Getting the lipstick wrong is really dumb.
Choiszt: 还有那个沙发上的东西也收一下
Choiszt: Also, clear the stuff on the couch.
Nicous: 靠这是中文
Nicous: Man, it's in Chinese.
Katrina:  你特别像那北京大爷
Katrina: You really seem like one of those Beijing old guys.
Katrina:  就是听别人在坐在那种相亲公园
Katrina: Just listening to people in a matchmaking park.
Katrina:  听别人讲然后开始点评
Katrina: Listening to others and then commenting.
Shure:  没有我只是觉得
Shure: No, I just think...
Katrina:  没事我已经习惯了
Katrina: It's okay, I'm used to it.
Katrina:  怎么吐槽我前男友都无所谓
Katrina: It doesn't matter how you complain about my ex-boyfriend.
Lucia: 这好像也没有袋子啥的可以给他
Lucia: Seems like there's no bag or anything to give him.
Lucia: 藏靠垫后面吧
Lucia: Hide it behind the cushion.
Katrina:  主要是
Katrina: The main thing is...
Katrina:  当然是他先删的我这一点让我很不爽
Katrina: He blocked me first, and that really pissed me off.
Katrina: 他先把我拉黑了
Katrina: He blocked me first.
Shure: 你现在把他加回去
Shure: Just add him back now.
Katrina: 全平台拉黑
Katrina: Blocked on all platforms.
Shure: 你再把他拉黑一遍
Shure: Then block him again.
Katrina:  给我张纸弄我
Katrina: Give me a piece of paper.
Katrina: 裤子上了
Katrina: It's on my pants.
Lucia: 我就姑且认为这就算是藏好了
Lucia: I'll just assume this is well hidden.
Katrina: 我加都不想加好吗
Katrina: I don't even want to add him, okay?
Katrina: 他当时考完研还给我发短信呢
Katrina: He texted me after finishing his exam.
Katrina: 因为只有短信这一条路
Katrina: Because texting was the only way.
Nicous:  他还有脸发短信
Nicous: He actually had the nerve to text.
Shure:  嗯就是
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  对对好搞笑你知道吗
Katrina: Right, it's so funny, you know?
Katrina:  搞笑的要命
Katrina: Ridiculously funny.
Shure:  还需要吗
Shure: Do you still need it?
Katrina:  然后当时我就是属于呃
Katrina: And at that time, I was like, uh...
Katrina:  就是不想回也不想拉黑
Katrina: I didn't want to reply, but also didn't want to block him.
Nicous: 这两个的区别在于一个是中文一个是日文
Nicous: The difference is one is in Chinese and one is in Japanese.
Katrina:  哦也有可能跟版本有关
Katrina: Oh, it might also be related to the version.
Katrina:  但是这个牌子是日本牌子呀
Katrina: But this brand is Japanese.
Katrina: 差别不大啦你女朋友看不出来啦
Katrina: There's not much difference, your girlfriend won't notice.
Nicous: 直接得物买买不错
Nicous: Just buy it directly from Dewu, it's good.
Nicous: 直接得物买
Nicous: Just buy it directly from Dewu.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Katrina: 明天一天都在外面吗
Katrina: Are you out all day tomorrow?
Katrina: 这还有佛教的东西
Katrina: There's also some Buddhist stuff here.
Shure: 南无吧那南无
Shure: Namo, yes, Namo.
Shure: 菩萨般的南无
Shure: Namo like a bodhisattva.
Katrina: 我还要去雍和宫还个愿呢
Katrina: I still need to go to Yonghe Temple to fulfill a vow.
Nicous: 我靠我觉得雍和宫一点都不准
Nicous: Oh man, I think Yonghe Temple is not accurate at all.
Katrina: 啊我觉得特别准当时求财运
Katrina: Ah, I think it's super accurate, I prayed for wealth.
Katrina: 财运还不错
Katrina: And my wealth luck was pretty good.
Shure: 我妈还
Shure: My mom still...
Shure:  你什么时候还愿的
Shure: When did you fulfill your vow?
Nicous: 我就没求财运
Nicous: I didn't pray for wealth.
Nicous: 我就应该去求财运
Nicous: I should have prayed for wealth.
Katrina: 当时我自己求的财运
Katrina: At that time, I prayed for wealth myself.
Katrina: 给我两个好朋友求的考研上岸
Katrina: And for two of my good friends to pass their exams.
Katrina: 那两个都上岸了其他没上岸
Katrina: Those two passed, the others didn't.
Shure: 我妈我妈让我给我妹求的学业
Shure: My mom, my mom asked me to pray for my sister's studies.
Katrina: 学业应该也还行
Katrina: Studies should be fine too.
Katrina:  我就带着这手串一直带
Katrina: I just always wear this bracelet.
Katrina:  我开光了
Katrina: I had it blessed.
Katrina:  我当时还跪在第第一排
Katrina: I even knelt in the first row at that time.
Nicous: 你是在雍和宫里面买的
Nicous: You bought it inside the Yonghe Temple.
Katrina:  嗯然后去开光
Katrina: Yeah, and then I got it blessed.
Nicous: 380
Nicous: 380.
Katrina: 280这个是280
Katrina: 280, this one's 280.
Nicous: 你知道当时我是怎么买的吗我去
Nicous: Do you know how I bought it back then? I went to...
Nicous: 那个叫什么
Nicous: What's it called...
Shure: 外面那个什么
Shure: Outside, that place...
Nicous: 都不是我都不是在外面那边
Nicous: No, no, not outside, not there.
Shure:  法物流通处
Shure: The Dharma objects shop.
Katrina:  就是法物流通处
Katrina: Yeah, the Dharma objects shop.
Nicous: 就那个最便宜那个地方
Nicous: The cheapest place there.
Katrina:  啊叫叫叫叫叫
Katrina: Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  就是那个卖手串的集市是吧
Katrina: The market that sells bracelets, right?
Katrina: 叫什么来着三个字
Katrina: What's it called, three words...
Nicous: 对对对就里面好多卖眼镜的
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, the place with many glasses shops.
Katrina: 北京
Katrina: Beijing...
Tasha: 潘家园
Tasha: Panjiayuan.
Lucia: 哦想了半天
Lucia: Oh, took me a while to remember.
Shure:  你他妈潘家园跟北新桥离多远呢
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Beixinqiao?
Shure: 潘家园跟雍和宫离多远啊
Shure: And how far is Panjiayuan from Yonghe Temple?
Nicous: 是远但是那边手串
Nicous: It's far, but the bracelets there...
Katrina: 手款式是一模一样的
Katrina: The styles are exactly the same.
Nicous: 三十块钱一个
Nicous: Thirty yuan each.
Nicous: 然后买了
Nicous: And I bought it.
Shure: 那他们能一样吗
Shure: Are they really the same?
Nicous: 一模一样
Nicous: Exactly the same.
Katrina: 据说应该是有正版和盗版的区别吧
Katrina: I heard there's a difference between genuine and fake ones.
Katrina: 但是这个心诚则灵还是买正版吧
Katrina: But if you believe in it, it's better to buy the genuine one.
Katrina:  当时也没想到我
Katrina: I didn't think...
Katrina:  还会来北京你知道吗
Katrina: I would come back to Beijing, you know?
Shure: 我需要充电我需要充电
Shure: I need to charge, I need to charge.
Katrina: 这充电宝没了吗
Katrina: Is the power bank dead?
Shure:  哎这充电宝没了
Shure: Yeah, the power bank's dead.
Lucia: 这个呢哎这好像不是
Lucia: How about this one? Oh wait, this isn't...
Shure:  这是我我自个的充电宝
Shure: This is my own power bank.
Shure:  但是没有
Shure: But it doesn't...
Lucia: 我是说这好像不是公共充电宝
Lucia: I mean this isn't the communal power bank.
Shure:  没有没有线了
Shure: No, there's no cable.
Shure:  我需要充电
Shure: I need to charge.
Lucia: 你是手机还是眼镜要充电了
Lucia: Do you need to charge your phone or your glasses?
Shure:  手机手机手机
Shure: Phone, phone, phone!
Lucia: 我刚好像在这看到
Lucia: I think I saw one here.
Lucia: 有一个
Lucia: There's one.
Lucia: 不过这上面连不知道连着谁的线呢
Lucia: But I don't know whose wire it's connected to.
Shure:  没事拔了
Shure: Just unplug it.
Shure:  给他拔了给他拔了
Shure: Unplug it, unplug it.
Lucia: 眼镜的线
Lucia: The glasses wire.
Katrina: 哇明天又是大晴天做好防晒
Katrina: Wow, it's going to be sunny again tomorrow. Better prepare sun protection.
Shure:  只有周六周日是那个阴天
Shure: Only Saturday and Sunday are cloudy.
Shure:  剩下咱们几天都是大晴天
Shure: The rest of the days are all sunny.
Katrina:  哇那我真运气好
Katrina: Wow, I'm really lucky.
Katrina:  在这唉哦
Katrina: To be here, oh.
Lucia: 哦这个没电了
Lucia: Oh, this one's out of battery.
Katrina:  明天28度呢我去
Katrina: It's going to be 28 degrees tomorrow, wow.
Lucia: 这不能征用了
Lucia: We can't use this one.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 你滚啊
Shure: Get lost!
Shure:  怎么会呢
Shure: How could that be?
Nicous:  嗯他说他就想要这个的
Nicous: Yeah, he said he wanted this one.
Nicous:  左边那是不是就是自然黑啊
Nicous: Isn't the one on the left natural black?
Shure: 我除了跟你喝多
Shure: Besides drinking a lot with you,
Shure: 会跟哪个女生喝多呀
Shure: who else would I drink a lot with?
Katrina: 用睫毛打底再用睫毛膏
Katrina: Use mascara base first, then mascara.
Shure: 什么可惜啊
Shure: What's the pity?
Katrina: 睫毛膏就买刚刚的那KISSME的
Katrina: For mascara, just buy that KISSME one.
Katrina:  攻略做的不错啊你女朋友
Katrina: Your girlfriend's guide is pretty good.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  刚那个吃饭的时候喝了一杯
Shure: I had a drink during dinner.
Shure:  然后自己库库库喝
Shure: Then I kept drinking.
Shure:  然后就喝
Shure: And then I drank more.
Shure:  有一点点多吧
Shure: Maybe a bit too much.
Katrina:  我西海子公园评分4.8呢我去
Katrina: My rating for Xihai Park is 4.8, wow.
Shure:  等你呢等你呢好吧
Shure: Waiting for you, waiting for you, alright.
Katrina:  这时候可以拿我的风格了
Katrina: Now I can use my style.
Shure: 你好烦哦
Shure: You're so annoying.
Katrina:  这公园有那什么大摆锤什么的玩
Katrina: This park has things like the big pendulum ride.
Katrina:  这会得甩掉吧
Katrina: You have to shake it off now.
Katrina: 算了这个
Katrina: Forget it then.
Nicous: 我想问个问题代购他能发的很快吗还是发的很慢
Nicous: I want to ask, can the purchasing agent ship quickly or slowly?
Katrina:  基本发的还挺快的
Katrina: They usually ship pretty fast.
Nicous: 他说写的什么
Nicous: What did he write?
Katrina:  你问客服
Katrina: Ask customer service.
Katrina:  问一下客服
Katrina: Just ask customer service.
Nicous:  他一般写预售都是不一定的是吧
Nicous: He usually writes pre-orders, it's not always certain, right?
Katrina: 应该是可以当天发
Katrina: It should be shipped the same day.
Katrina: 因为他们基本上都是专柜采购的
Katrina: Because they mostly buy directly from the store.
Katrina:  除非那个海淘会很慢
Katrina: Unless it's overseas shopping, which can be slow.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Katrina: 你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you coming again tomorrow?
Nicous: 应该吧可能吧怎么说
Nicous: Maybe, probably, how to say...
Nicous: 你们明天是要出去
Nicous: Are you going out tomorrow?
Katrina:  他说就明天户外
Katrina: He said we're going outdoors tomorrow.
Alice: 露西你见我的线了吗
Alice: Lucia, have you seen my thread?
Lucia: 呃在这里
Lucia: Uh, it's here.
Shure:  好困啊
Shure: I'm so sleepy.
Katrina:  我想洗澡呀
Katrina: I want to take a shower.
Shure: 洗过了
Shure: Already did.
Katrina:  就去西海子公园吧
Katrina: Let's just go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  唱吧你就
Shure: Just sing, will you?
Katrina:  通利弗尼亚
Katrina: Tonglifonia.
Katrina:  我真笑死
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter.
Alice: 你的手串
Alice: Your bracelet.
Shure:  啊我的我的我的
Shure: Ah, mine, mine, mine.
Katrina:  北京艺术中心
Katrina: Beijing Art Center.
Katrina:  哎北京好适合带富士相机
Katrina: Hey, Beijing is perfect for a Fujifilm camera.
Shure:  是的我跟你讲
Shure: Yes, I'm telling you.
Tasha: 拍出来很好看
Tasha: The photos come out great.
Katrina:  哎我要搞电脑了
Katrina: Hey, I need to work on the computer.
Shure:  杨老板还没扫好吗
Shure: Has Jake finished scanning yet?
Katrina:  因为等我们出门估计又2点多然后
Katrina: Because when we head out, it'll be past 2 again, and...
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  这公园还挺漂亮
Katrina: This park is pretty nice.
Katrina:  OK就西海子公园
Katrina: Okay, let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  切更像大爷了哈
Katrina: You're starting to look more like an old man.
Shure:  你就拉着人家唱你这个你你唱的歌吧
Shure: Just pull them in to sing your song, the one you sing.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Shure:  他们听过这歌吗
Shure: Have they heard this song?
Choiszt: OK可以下楼了下楼吧去外面待着
Choiszt: OK, we can go downstairs now. Let's go outside and hang out.